Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Thank you for waking up for us and joining us today for our 103rd episode!
BAU BAU!
Everything is normal.
You just got up, but you just got up!
That's amazing.
But it's not normal because today is gonna be a good day that starts off on the right paw.
I hope every day is a good day that starts off on the right paw.
But it's gonna be an extra special one.
Extra special normal day!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I see a lot of new Ruffians.
I think maybe some are joining us from... Five Nights at Freddy's!
Is that it?
Five Nights at Freddy's?
From BAU BAU?
From Five Nights at Freddy's.
Did we say it?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
To explain about FUWAMOCO Morning.
You know it's your first time joining us.
It wouldn't be good if you're confused right off the morning.
No.
Yeah, well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
I'm sorry I'm busy laughing here.
Why are you laughing, Moco-chan?
I fused off the morning.
What does that mean?
But, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ah, we skipped Nato one day!
That's fine.
No one will cry.
No one will cry, Ruffians.
Ruffians, you could've cried, right?
Did we?
Moco-chan, the Ruffians are crying!
Did we skip Nato one day?
Really?
You see the Nato coming out of their eyes right now!
That's not healthy.
Maybe you should go to the doctor, huh?
Huh?
BAU BAU!
You're happy for Moco-chan.
Thank you.
Well, it's gonna be a good Wednesday, a good middle of the week.
Moco-chan.
Why are you making that noise?
Except for this.
There's been another Pero Sighting!
I don't know.
Every time it's a bit of a downer.
But, maybe it's better to get the downers out of the way first?
I feel like Pero's been kinda nice recently, you know?
Not really getting in our way.
Doing some nice things.
Right!
Ruffians, don't we like Pero?
Wait, I don't know.
Let's see, Ruffians!
You say that right now, but...
De-den!
These are the Warehouse Coins!
FUWAMOCO Warehouse Coins!
FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAMOCO FUWAM
It also looks like you got pero.
But maybe... Is this Ruffian doesn't seem to mind?
Are you sure?
You didn't feel like, ah, this is awful.
Anyone else would have been better, right?
Really?
Really, really?
Are you sure you're not forgetting someone?
I love you.
What about Mococo?
What about Nerissa, ha, Moco-chan?
Here's a bonerisa.
I can't bonerisa.
Wow.
We're glad that you had amazing gacha luck.
No, Moco-chan got Pero.
I guess that's okay.
And we hope it continues forever and ever, right?
Right, Moco-chan?
Okay.
Yeah, because that means that this Ruffian will then get Moco-chan too, right?
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I guess it's good that you got Pero.
That makes you happy.
BAU BAU.
Forget Nerissa.
BAU BAU!
We're Ruffians!
We might kinda have a bit of an apology to make.
Ruffians, we're really really sorry.
Did you know?
Didn't notice.
Maybe there's some Ruffians here that didn't notice, but actually, for the first time ever ever, we had to cancel a FUWAMOCO Morning.
And very suddenly too.
Yeah, up until now, you know, a few hours beforehand.
A few hours, yeah.
But up until now, you know, every single FUWAMOCO Morning, every single one since we debuted,
Every single one has happened until now.
We know no oversleeping, no sickness.
Every single one.
We power through them all.
But on Monday, we had to cancel.
Ruffians, there was a really really good reason though.
So uh, thank you for understanding!
Yeah!
You see!
Wow, FUWAMOCO!
It was a really crazy intense day!
Crazy!
FUWAMOCO!
We have been up from early early morning!
Really really early!
Yeah, until late night working so hard!
Like dogs!
Like dogs and dogs and dogs!
We're working hard all together with all of Advent too!
Despite being super tired puppies, you know, we're like, okay, yep.
We're going to do a FUWAMOCO Morning as always, you know, because we wanted to make sure to start the week off on the right paw together with you.
That's what we had planned.
You know, we even haven't had dinner.
And Nerissa and Biboo are gonna go out to get something yummy.
And we said, no.
Like we've done many times before, you know?
We have an important engagement with the Ruffians, right?
But then... Actually...
Suisei-senpai came in!
BAU BAU!
Those Suisei-senpais came in like a comet!
Like a comet!
And it was our first time meeting Suisei-senpai and we were so surprised!
Yeah.
Suisei-senpai, she asked what our plans were because our busy day was now over.
And we said, you know, we have FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
You know, that's what we have planned.
That's what we are gonna do.
But then she was like, oh, FUWAMOCO, you'll come to Yakiniku with all of us, right?
Right.
And Ruffians... We knew what we had to do.
You know, because if THE Suisei Senpai... THE Suisei Senpai... If she asks you to dinner, what do you say, Ruffians?
Are you gonna ignore our comment?
You can't do that.
Huh?
Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah, we're so excited, so nervous, but really, really, really happy to have dinner with her, you know.
FUWAMOCO, we really respect and admire Senpai so much.
Of course.
And we're really happy to be able to have the opportunity to ask her a bunch of questions!
So many questions, always!
We got a lot of Senpai power from her.
I was sitting directly across from Suisei-senpai!
And every time she cooked a piece of meat for me and put it on my plate, I felt like I was gonna cry, Ruffians!
You were crying, right?
I'm Suisei-senpai BAU BAU!
This isn't the time for that!
FUWAMOCO, maybe we're not the best at yakiniku.
We're probably not the best people to invite to yakiniku.
Because I...
We scream.
We're babies when it comes to yakiniku.
We don't know what to do.
And the fire is scary.
So we scream and we can't control ourselves.
Suisei-senpai was laughing at us.
And it's not like we were forced to go to dinner with Dai-senpai.
We wanted to go, you know?
Of course.
Hi.
And you know, it's not like there's ever gonna be another chance when we can go out to dinner with Nerissa and Biboo and Suisei-senpai!
Yeah.
It's very slim.
It felt like a dream.
Yeah, and we wanted to take the opportunity too!
Yeah!
You know, cause Suisei-senpai is very, very, very cute, right?
Yeah.
We hope you understand, Ruffians!
You know, it wasn't a decision that we made lightly.
No.
Uh-uh.
But we were just really really happy because we were able to share with Suisei-senpai just how hungry we were!
But not in the yakiniku way.
In the ambitious way.
Yeah, but we weren't hungry afterwards.
We were, no, we were done.
But Suisei-senpai also said that she'll be cheering us on too!
And you know what?
Nerissa and Biboo and I were actually laughing to each other.
Because when we were walking back, Fuwawa and Suisei-senpai were walking together, and Nerissa was like, oh, it looks like they're on a date together, huh?
I was trying to be the coolest demon dog I could be a Ruffian.
Although I wasn't looking very cool at the time.
You're probably looking like a big ball of mess, huh?
I'm very sweaty.
Comments are hot, you know.
Thank you Suisei-senpai for treating us to delicious yakiniku!
And for giving us lots of amazing advice and support!
Thank you!
Arigatou!
That one day, maybe FUWAMOCO, we can become amazing members of hololive just like our Suisei-senpai is too.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You understand?
Understandable.
Understandable?
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
It feels like a dream.
It felt like a dream at the moment.
Ray's dream.
Yeah.
Ray's dreams.
Happy but strange.
Speaking of dreams, over the weekend I had a really funny dream.
There was a new generation of hololive English called Justice that debuted!
I think there was... It wasn't a dream, Moco-chan!
I think there was... Oh my gosh, Ruffians!
You're over the weekend!
The newest generation of hololive English!
Justice!
I made the debut!
BAU BAU!
We are officially senpai!
Crazy dream, right?
It was so, so nice to see you debut and get kohai!
You know from...
The love to be held now and then.
Cecilia.
Ellen Elizabeth Rose Bluffling.
Ellen Gigi.
Yeah!
It was nice that, you know, all of Advent, we were able to do a off-cloud watch-a-meow.
We had our debuters from the studio.
And it was really, it was just so nice.
It was very cute to see them do their best.
Debuting, remembering, that was us.
Yeah, it made us all a bit nostalgic, huh?
Yeah, this, this demon- FUWAMOCO-senpai!
Yeah, this demon girl was feeling like a, a very, uh, mature puppy at that moment.
Yeah.
You know?
Time flies, right?
It was just so much fun cheering them on.
Yeah!
But, uh, we're definitely not gonna let them catch us, you know?
But, but, you know, it needs to be said.
But, but,
Yeah, just like that.
Yeah.
That's a senpai's job, right?
Good senpai behavior!
Exactly!
We've already got to see so much of their personalities.
Right?
And they released an amazing original song too.
Yeah!
And, you know, Elizabeth's already done a bunch of karaoke!
Right!
But I was really curious!
Huh?
I wanna see, you know, I wanna see Elizabeth... She did a really good Alvin impersonation in BAU BAU.
But I haven't seen a Pero impersonation, right?
We don't need that.
He's nasty.
I wanna see Elizabeth's Pero impersonation, right, Ruffians?
Right!
Hmm...
Biboonita!
Which one is it?
Cecilia too, you know?
We made plans to rip off her head, right?
Yes, we did make plans for that.
After we rip off her head... And I had to rub our fingers on her joints.
That too, I guess.
But you know, I thought it'd be fun that after we try ripping off her head, then we could drink tea together and see how that goes.
Right!
Where would it go, huh?
I don't know, we have to see!
We have to try!
Right!
Alright!
I could try something, Moco-chan.
Cecelia could take a drink from the tea.
And then we could see if it falls out of the neck.
Then maybe we could drink from that.
Wait, Ruffians!
It's an idea!
Yeah!
An idea!
Right!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I don't know.
Maybe... You know, you power up a bit if you got some of Gigi's grammar power.
I wonder how I can do that.
Maybe you could just take a finger off of her something.
Just a bite.
BAU BAU!
Good senpai, right?
Thank you!
Right, Ruffian?
Welcome to FUWAMOCO!
It's been exciting, huh, Ruffians?
It's been very exciting, yeah.
Just take a yobi-yobi.
BAU BAU!
On the topic of... Moco-chan!
On the topic of exciting!
On the topic of figs.
No, no, no, no!
This is on the topic of figs!
Figs!
Ruffians, we had some amazing
News!
We're so happy to let you know, but FUWAMOCO!
We're gonna be special guests at Good Smile Company's panel at Anime Expo!
BAU BAU!
BAU B
Are you going to be there, Ruffians?
Maybe you had some fun summer plans in LA?
If you did, maybe we'll see you there!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We are so, so incredibly honored and just absolutely thrilled to be a part of it.
You know how much we love figures, right?
FUWAMOCO, since we've been small little puppies, we've actually been collecting figures, and we love them so much!
And Good Smiles figures have been a very special part of our collection.
Even FUWAMOCO, we remember looking at the very first Nendoroid to come out, together with the mama puppy, and we were like, oh they're so cute!
So we collect them all!
We decided to only get our very favorite characters.
Which is a good decision.
Yeah, good decision.
There's over 2,000!
2,000 Nendoroids!
Yeah.
A good decision.
Good decision.
Yeah, I don't have a big enough doghouse for that many Nendoroids.
No, that's a lot of space.
Yeah.
But we'll be on the panel together with Yago-san himself and the founder of Good Smile Company, Takanori Aki.
We're super novice Ruffians!
What are we gonna do?
What should we do to be able to share our love for figures even more, Ruffians?
What are we gonna say?
Because you know... I think we're gonna say a bit more than that.
FUWAMOCO, what's your thoughts on this?
That's it, that's it.
I think we gotta do better than that.
So we're gonna do our best, okay?
I'll talk about your version and on.
What?
I know that the rarest nendoroid is Ryofuko-chan.
I wanted it.
It's really cute.
And I like the opening theme.
It's not gonna happen.
Never gonna happen.
But I think we have number 37.
Hostile Inc.
Tell them about your collection.
I don't know if it's the right time for that.
There's going to be announcements and prizes, so Ruffians, please don't forget about it, okay?
We hope that you'll be cheering on these geeky puppies that are in FUWAMOCO one-to-one.
You love too much though.
Since we're making our first appearance at Anime Expo, okay?
BAU BAU!
Let's all show our power together, okay?
I'm so excited but really nervous, but I'm more excited with Ruffians!
Breaking Dimensions!
BAU BAU!
hololive English's second content, Breaking Dimensions, is happening in August.
August 24th and 25th.
Anyways, we just announced that there's gonna be some guests!
First we have Kobo-senpai announced!
And now Muna-senpai!
And there's two more interesting shapes here.
Oh, this shape's called senpai.
Senpai shapes.
Who do you think these senpai shapes are?
Ruffians!
Two more?
Lump and Lumpy.
Lumpy Lumpy.
A slime.
Yes, a slime.
Pero!
I don't think it's Pero.
Why would anyone call him the guest on anything, huh?
Well, I heard YMCA is Pero's favorite song to sing, right?
You don't want to see that?
I don't know.
That would break too many dimensions, okay?
That's true.
Yeah, well, I'm sure we'll find out soon who these two muffy senpai shapes are.
But, most importantly, Ruffians, you might have kind of let your guard down.
But it's okay because these guard dogs, we have it for you.
I don't want that to happen.
No.
Yeah, the tickets that-
In-venue in-person tickets for Breaking Dimensions goes on sale on Friday the 28th at 6pm PT, 9pm EDT, or the 29th at 10am JST.
Really soon!
It's finally really soon!
We'll remind you again next FUWAMOCO Morning.
Ruffians that are a little bit far away from the King's Theatre in New York, there are online digital streaming tickets available right now.
Please go get them over on the SPW and on the Spawn website.
Because FUWAMOCO will be making our first concert appearance there too!
Yes!
Two days.
Not one day, Moco-chan.
Two days!
And Ruffians, if you thought you know that this is an amazing concert, I gotta get a t-shirt, I gotta get some merch.
Right now you can still get your merch set on the official hololive website.
It's actually extended, so if you're a little forgetful, it's okay, it happens.
You can still get it, but there is some unfortunate news.
The sets only come with one penlight.
So that means, you know, that maybe you might need two penlights.
Yeah, you might need to snag a friend's penlight.
Excuse me, I would like to borrow that there.
Buy two sets.
Or you could always make your own penlight.
Yeah!
We are alright.
Lots of ideas!
You can't have blue and pink at the same time.
You need two.
Okay.
There's still some time to figure out what to do with the dilemma.
Make your choices!
We hope that you look forward to it just as much as we are, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Is this something exciting, Moco-chan?
Is this something sad?
Well, we have some news, Ruffians.
Biboo was kidnapped.
She was kidnapped.
Kidnapped.
Kidnapped for good this time.
Yeah.
I swear that it's a bit alarming.
She was kidnapped.
Before Justice made their debut,
Biboo was kidnapped by a group of criminals.
Innocent criminals called Advent.
We had to kidnap her away from the pebbles while she was playing Elden Ring.
You know, cause she was having a lot of fun and then there was a legend of boss.
Yeah, you might not have heard it, but we broke down the door.
We broke down the door.
We stormed the room!
We stormed the room and told her, you have to get out!
I'm gonna turn off the computer!
And we even tickled her, Ruffians.
We even tickled her.
In a ticklish spot.
Yeah!
And she... She was gaming.
She did not react.
She was a rock.
Somehow that's surprising.
Yeah.
I don't know, when Biboo's gaming, she is gaming.
And I think Pebbles already realized this, but Biboo gaming is very cute.
But she was also sweating a lot too.
What?!
But that might have had to do with the fact that she was getting kidnapped by Alphys.
And tickled!
Yeah, yeah.
I did think, you know, I'm gonna pull the chair away, but I decided that that's maybe a bit too cool.
I know we talked about wanting to do that.
She's almost done with the boss, so... We showed mercy.
Just in time, Biboo was able to fell the hajimaru.
And made it in time for Justice's debut.
But if you want to hear what it sounds like for Advent to kidnap Biboo, go check it out.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, how has the week been going so far?
Hopefully you have some more energy.
But maybe you need a little bit of a push too.
Pick me up.
Moco-chan, you're still sleepy.
A bit rough.
Tough but going.
I get it.
It's been alright.
Could be better though, right?
Well, maybe you need a bit of a talk then!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
You're right!
It's time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
Mococo!
How are things been going, Ruffians?
You know, before we even realized it, it seems like we're in the thick of summer already!
Are you keeping your energy levels up?
You won't let the heat and the humidity zap it from you, right?
Right?
One thing that's important is that you make sure to keep yourself refreshed by not only just drinking water,
But by keeping up with trying out new things every now and then too.
You know?
It's always a great feeling of accomplishment when you can give yourself a pat on the back after trying something that was, uh, maybe a bit scary.
I know you can do it.
No matter what you think.
You're strong!
It won't faze you.
In the end, you'll be glad you tried and didn't regret it.
No matter the outcome, okay?
So, let's take control of this summer.
This summer of advent and say no!
Actually, this, this is the summer of me!
Let's all do our best to make it an unforgettable summer, okay?
Ganbatte desu!
BAU BAU!
The summer of Advent and the summer of you, Ruffians!
Wow, Moco-chan.
Maybe let's take a look at... Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
I feel like taking a look at the Doggie of the Day.
Who's the Doggie of the Day, Moco-chan?
The Doggie of the Day.
We have... What?
Stay foggy all the day!
We have is... De-den!
Winnie!
So cute!
She's goofy!
And has boobies!
And has butt scrunchies!
And adjustable anything that can fit in her mouth!
And has donuts!
And you know what?
I love Winnie!
Oh Winnie, look at Winnie's eyes!
That's a puppy!
Baby Fuwawa, excuse me!
Little baby Mococo, hi!
This is Mococo-chan!
Hi!
I think Winnie, Winnie, BAU BAU is like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
Winnie, Winnie.
Winnie, you're too cute.
Look at Winnie's ears.
My ears are cuter though.
BAU BAU!
Can we give Winnie a ranking?
A ranking?
A rating?
Ranking.
My brain is broken.
That's Winnie.
Winnie.
Breaker of brains.
That's it.
BAU BAU!
And let's take a look at the work we've been going over for you.
Today's work is... De-den!
Mococo Sky!
A FUWAMOCO colored sky above the snow.
A Mococo Sky!
No more white about Mococo, right?
Yeah, it's a Moco-chan sky.
Well, I hope you got home safe.
I'm gonna assume you got home safe since you uploaded this.
Twitter.
You don't want me to do that FUWMC.
I don't think a ghost can upload to Twitter, huh?
Well, I'm glad that, you know, you got to see a beautiful sky to calm you down after what I'm sure was a very busy day.
Right.
BAU BAU!
And for our Question of the Day, we have de-den!
Morning, FUWAMOCO!
Morning!
BAU BAU!
This question was in my mind for almost a year now.
How come, as demon guard dogs,
You decided to protect our smiles instead of steal them.
Aren't demons evil?
And we unintentionally sold our souls for this.
That's a very cute illustration.
A very accurate one of FUWAMOCO.
But to answer your question, you know, sometimes, and this isn't everyone, but sometimes people don't want their smiles protected.
So, you know, we try to ask, you know, is it okay if we protect your smile?
We try.
Is it okay to boil your smile?
Is
Whether you like it or not!
We'll protect it, okay?
Very demonic, right?
Resistance is futile.
FUWAMOCO!
It's futile.
Got it.
That's why.
That's why these puppies are demon-grinded.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We're always looking for new submissions.
Your puppy's very cute puppy winning today.
Your doggies, your questions, all of them.
So please let us know what's on your mind with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
And for our next stream,
We have... De-den!
The game of sis-fuyus.
Yeah.
We're gonna be rolling a big rock each.
One rock for me, one rock for you.
I'm not gonna have to share the rock.
Because we're versusing each other.
Yeah, sister versus sister.
Yeah, who is the strongest.
Right.
Who can push it the farthest.
Yeah.
That's what we're gonna be doing.
So Ruffians, we'll need you to kinda help us.
Maybe let us know what to avoid.
Let us know how to beat each other up.
Yeah!
Because we're gonna roll the rock.
We'll find the ultimate winner.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
After that, well, on Thursday we're playing Portal 2 together!
Yeah!
Cool!
We've never played Portal before but we've heard a lot of Ruffians suggesting FUWAMOCO you should check it out!
And we're always interested in playing fun games because all games are fun to us!
So we're gonna do our best and see just how much fun Portal 2 is!
BAU BAU!
And then of course we have FUWAMOCO Off Morning on Friday!
So we hope that you'll wake up and join us for the last FUWAMOCO Morning of the week.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians who are joining us through the archives today, here is your FUWAMOCO word to write in the comments.
It's BAU BAU!
Versus Battle!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians!
Dewey Mendez.
BAU BAU!
Hiromiyo.
Jyarei Door.
BAU BAU!
Setsukiyo.
Nanoi.
BAU BAU!
Carnyx.
Pawsome.
Tiny Spaceman.
Asteroids.
Fuki.
Liang.
Add to every other Ruffian out there.
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!